that was like three and a half four
years ago as I was finishing up when he
the poo but actually you know it
actually goes much deeper than that and
farther back in time than that and it
goes back about 40 years actually if you
really want to know and and because when
i was a kid i grew up with two passions
i loved two things more than anything in
the world I love Marvel Comics and I
love disney animation and it's where I
fell in love with drawing it's where I
fell in love with storytelling graphic
storytelling and I ended up pursuing
obviously the the Disney passion but
really you know this this film came out
it was born out of that and that's what
John always asked us to start with as a
director you know what are you
passionate about and yeah that's the
first question you have to ask yourself
you know when you're when you're
pitching ideas and so I swear this is
true i had a five minute conversation
with john about the possibility of doing
finding something in the Marvel treasure
trove of characters and stories and
bringing it over into animation and he
loved the idea and he said go find
something and so I just started looking
into my past and and thinking about the
the stuff that I loved as a kid I grew
up in the 70s so Marvel you know was the
Big Bang of Marvel was in the 60s but by
the 70s they were really hitting their
stride and so I just started making
lists and and I started doing research
and again John was excited I was excited
and I came across this gem this little
gems um that was little known called big
hero 6 and what attracted me to it was
the title to be perfectly honest I'd
never read them before and and I just
thought it sounded cool and so I looked
it up and it said Japanese superhero
team even cooler and so and I finally
got my hands on some of the comics and
and I just kind of fell in love with the
characters I thought they were fun and
appealing I thought they were kind of
broad characters that would translate
well to animation and you could tell
that the creators of the the book really
love Japanese pop culture in fact the
whole thing felt like a love letter to
Japan I mean there were references to
miyazaki and you know stuff that only
like true nerds would know you know like
me and and it just had a cool feel to it
and but at the core of it we saw that
there could be a really emotional story
between this 14 year old super genius
who loses his older brother and this
robot who essentially
comes his healer and his surrogate big
brother and and so I pitched big hero 6
along with about five or six other
Marvel titles to to John and he
immediately gravitated towards this one
and it was because of the emotional
story you know I think he would just it
really spoke to him and so he on the
spot green let it and said okay get
going didn't you didn't intentionally
dampen down the other ones you know I'll
be perfectly honest bill I myself and
some of the other artists had done
actually quite a bit of artwork for a
lot of the other projects this is the
one we didn't do any artwork for it was
the smallest if you think of our story
rooms the the boards lined to the room
so all of the pitches lined the room and
and they got progressively smaller
because as you know with less artwork
and this is the one that had no artwork
just a cover like I think I had maybe
the pictures of the covers but that
spark you could feel it right away it
was that emotional story motional core
was there he lit up in that that was
what do you know immediately he was like
that's the one and so we called a
meeting with Marvel and said John picked
big hero 6 and into marvel I mean it was
one of them you know this is one of the
lesser-known properties that they had
done and look it up and so they you know
we called a meeting with all their guys
and and joe quesada who is their chief
creative officer he sort of the John
Lasseter of Marvel I guess and Jeph Loeb
and those two became instrumental in
this project but so we had a meeting
with all Marvel guys and they were
thrilled and excited and they really
encouraged us to make it our own they
said don't worry about trying to you
know set this in the Marvel Universe and
trying to weave in all the the separate
storylines that are and mind you this
was like pre Avengers I think I don't
think Captain America had come out yet
so they had this grand plan this grand
scheme that they all had worked out and
they said don't worry about trying to
weave into that create take this and
make it your own create your own world
and which was really gracious of them
and also very exciting for us and so we
started thinking about ok if this isn't
the marvel universe which is essentially
New York I remember in the comic books
it was always New York City and it gets
destroyed one week and it's rebuilt in
the next week and it's fine but uh
that's sort of the epicenter of the
Marvel Universe the hub of the Marvel
Universe is New York City and so
obviously when we're going to set it
there and we wanted to keep like the
Japanese aesthetic from the comic books
so we thought let's create a you know
sort of a fictional a fantasy world that
combined this Japanese aesthetic with a
real city and I chose San Francisco
because it just felt very iconic you
know if we put this sort of Japanese
makeover over it it would create
something new but it's still
recognizable there's still a lot of
iconic things that people would
recognize like cable cars and you know
the hills and and golden gate bridge and
what have you and so and at first we
just dubbed it San fransokyo kind of
jokingly it's just such a you know a
literal mashup of two of these cities
but the name stuck because it was kind
of cute and funny and so now we had our
world we had our universe which is going
to be San fransokyo and it was going to
be this sort of high-tech mashup of of
Tokyo in San Francisco and so so now we
have our world but we don't we never
start going into story we hold that off
for a while you know we had the paramus
but now we had our world and then the
next phase of what we do and it's
actually to me one of the most important
things what we do is research and we do
deep dives and we really immerse
ourselves and so one of the first things
we did was obviously went to Tokyo I
think I was there for like 13 days took
thousands and thousands of pictures and
and walk the city from one end to the
other and just really immersed ourselves
in the culture she's trying to pick up
as much of the the feeling of the city
is the actual you know details and I was
really impressed with just how modern
Tokyo was I mean I knew it was a modern
city but it was like it just felt like
it was it was the future you were
looking at the future when you looked at
Tokyo but then right next to it you know
certain in certain areas you would see
like a really old building too so I had
that mix of old and new and the other
thing that really impressed me was just
sort of them the way they organized
their visual density it's a very dense
City obviously and it's very populated
and so but it never felt you know
cluttered to me and always felt ordered
and I wanted to make sure we capture
that in addition to if you see the big
cute sign that I don't know if you know
what that is a big monkey headed man but
there's just a lot of really cuteness in
in the graphic signage around there we
want to make sure we got that in there
too